[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record when we talk about
whatever
we want what do you want to talk about
joe
moving to vegas we say this all the time
like we want to move to vegas
no no no no who derailed the train
though cause i was mister let's move you
did because you bought a house and then
i remember
when you buy the house well right but no
i know but that was after i already
bought the house anyway and
and but that was i was i was just going
to tell you who really did dell the
train
yeah who this lady named [ __ ]
martha
one lady hey is that my mom martha
stewart
[ __ ] martha didn't want to move
and all of a sudden
all of a sudden this [ __ ] [ __ ] tells
us that she's down all of a sudden we're
like
she is thanks for [ __ ] telling us
after we bought it when did that happen
when she was like you know what
like she doesn't have an accent
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i know but it's funnier you know what
miho
[Laughter]
i think it's time we go to vegas yeah
what did you say how did it come up is
something like that uh we were we were
talking about we're talking about how
like i just brought it up i was just
like hey so i think the conversation
about moving again is
is like we're talking about and i think
we're being way more serious now
uh so we started giving our details uh
as to why we wanted to move
the biggest one being just the money
like the tax and stuff
i'm like would you ever consider it
cause like we don't want to leave
because we want our family to be close
to us
and she goes with all these earthquakes
and stuff that like people are
predicting is gonna happen this year
uh yeah i don't want to avoid that at
all because i'm really considering it
because i was oh so the earthquakes got
her yeah i was eating
yeah i was expecting the same usual
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] martha spews
which is like i'm
back here i'm not gonna [ __ ] go
anywhere and i'm eating and she goes
yeah the earthquakes i'm like
she's down i like how it was one
fear was stronger than the other fear
that drove her
it's not a desire yeah it was the
original fear oh yeah she just moves she
just makes decisions
she doesn't want to change up her life
yet because she's been living in a
certain way for
60 years um if you think about it though
nevada doesn't have any natural
disasters
they don't get earthquakes at all
because they're right next door
it's hot as [ __ ] for sure there's like a
weird energy there where like just dead
bodies probably all around you there's
20 000
there's 20 000 homeless people under the
city like the amount of people that have
killed themselves in vegas hotel rooms
and like it scares the [ __ ] everywhere
yeah so you guys should never
go out there don't don't do it don't you
go to the pioneers we're gonna make sure
it's safe for you guys first so just
wait for us to get there first
give us 10 years and then we'll give you
the status report so one of our fans is
a security there and we're hanging out
at the uh
mgm and then he was like so uh
basically a third of people
that come to vegas they come to get
married they come for conventions
or they come to die why die that's how
many people come to die
yeah it's like it's one of those
understated things that goes on in vegas
they don't promote enough yeah they
don't want to promote we could have had
somebody
that just died and then we checked into
the hotel room
honestly yeah and that's isn't that
crazy yeah it makes me feel like oh we
we're going to a haunted house ghost
store yeah
there might be a portal to either hell
or heaven in vegas
yeah i mean probably maybe both well
dude because some cats they just go
there with the last bit of their money
and then they just go all in
and then whatever happens it's crazy it
feels so good but it feels so wrong
right i get why they got it you're like
gambling and it feels good because you
think you're gonna win and then that
hope makes you happy and then you lose
and you go i lost everything or maybe
they went on a cool six hour run and
then they lost it all at the end they're
like [ __ ]
yeah i should have i should catch that
everything on black i'm running
yeah so i was talking to our financial
advisor
yeah who's related to joe yeah but um
and like the more i talk to them about
taxes in different states i'm like
why the [ __ ] am i still here yeah
because i guess one of the biggest
things in california
capital gains or like money you make on
investments or anything
everything is just included into income
and we all know that california like
taxes on income like a [ __ ] so
if you
sold your house or whatever or if you
sold your business or if your crypto or
your stocks or anything they just all
categorized into that
one income that you made that year yeah
nevada
they separate the two because there's
people that have winnings all the time
right because of their gambling whatever
so because of that
if you sell your crypto or you sell your
house or you sell your business or
whether you do whatever it's
separated and they also don't even have
the income tax to begin with
so i'm just like [ __ ] you get screwed
like a [ __ ] if there's a huge
california exit is you know that right
like elon's trying to leave joe rogan's
he's set up already all right i think
he's leaving it's a lot it's because
uh it's it's like people are getting
pretty much
taxed like crazy especially with this
100 million dollar deal
yeah like do you want to immediately
take like 40 of it 40 million
right because he's a he's not married
right he's a single male no he's married
oh he is okay he's like two kids i think
well i thought he had kids but i didn't
know he was married oh okay
he's like do you want to take the
hundred million immediately kiss 40
million goodbye
or you know it's really infuriating too
it's like we don't even see our tax
money really put to work exactly
that's what drives me crazy it goes on
the roads tiff but the roads are so
[ __ ] up
beautiful roads but in the rich
neighborhood all right yeah right so
let's let's
look at some [ __ ] up let's look at
cities that have better tax laws right
like that
like phoenix or like uh uh if we think
about like
texas even texas right any outside of
california 80
yeah so like why the [ __ ] are their
streets and everything
so much better cleaner and everything
when they pay less taxes i don't get
where the money's going or how about
this
why the [ __ ] when we're in quarantine
didn't they fix the roads when no one's
using them and they're starting to fix
the roads now now that we're back out
working
it's the best and they fixed a very
small road during quarantine i was like
you
[ __ ] i see you well another reason
why is i heard that
california has a [ __ ] ton of corruption
and politics like
we lost um like two or three million or
billion dollars
on the rail system that we were supposed
to build well look no one can find it
look at our governor has slicked back
here
that's corruption that's bad and he's
kind of too good looking to be a
politician yeah he looks like a vampire
more than
exactly i would be so down to get taxed
if i saw everything being used yeah like
if the entire state of california
california looked like anaheim that'd be
amazing oh
yeah or irvide irvine is
sick yeah that's how i feel about
federal taxes whenever i see a drone
video of a terrorist getting blown to
smithereens i'm like that's my money
being put together you bring up a good
point because like orange county
even though they're the mask shamers um
because if you wear a mask they shame
you you know but like
but they're they're more quote-unquote
like a republican kind of place right so
then they're more business friendly and
they
they tax less but why is it that a lot
of their cities
are just cleaner better and like
everything i heard it was because disney
puts in
into the city there's ugly parts of
anaheim i'm talking more like
um like irvine newport huntington
um that's just beach city parts of costa
mesa there's a lot of shitty
cities though like for example i have
venice very small parts of santa ana is
nice yeah i grew up in orange county
most of orange county is not nice oh
yeah is it yeah it's pretty ghetto for a
certain point yeah well
north orange county by the by the long
beach so even when you think of anaheim
like there's nicknames for you you have
ana crime
really yeah there's ghetto parts of
every city yeah
you have disneyland and that's a safe
haven and then you have the beach cities
and then you have irvine which is like
an up-and-coming place i think from a la
perspective though
like i go to the hood of santa ana and
i'm like
damn this is so nice here you know it's
just the difference that's the ones i'm
looking at
of santa ana is still better than the
ghetto of
l.a yes yeah i don't know i think i
think that
disney's doing a good job putting money
in the area though like but except for
in toontown
yeah exactly thank god i don't know i
think this is like big people talk
though because i think
if if you're an employee you don't
really care too much about how taxes
work because you get taxed first before
you get your paycheck
but when you become a freelancer when
you become a business owner when you
start investing into things
that's when things start to change and
you're just like oh [ __ ] there's a whole
different world here that i didn't know
we have we have friends that work like
nine to five government jobs
and they just moved out of california
just because they don't even like the
civil unrest that's going on so in
california really you know there's
people that just don't
there's like super like left places
super right places we can't really come
together because we're not on the same
page
other states they're like let's do this
everyone's like cool let's go do that
so they can actually get things done
regardless if it's left or right driven
because
they're on the same page they're just
tired there's more unity yeah they're
just tired of people
fighting instead of actually moving
forward that's true
because california is like really polar
because people think it's a blue state
but it's only the main
major cities like if you go out to like
big bear or palmdale or whatever
as soon as you leave this area it's more
um conservative yeah it's super
conservative we went out to
i forgot which city it feels like
bakersfield or something i don't
remember but
we went out to go what kind of names did
they call you really bad ones so i think
it was like around there
yeah no but anyway like casey said he
noticed that one of the
the people that were talking to they had
like an all lives matter bracelet
and i was like whoa they have all lives
matter bracelets what the [ __ ]
yeah you got a profit on everything damn
so is that like gang i think it's so
commercial now black lives matter and
then all lives matter you have to fight
now if you see people wearing rival
bracelets i don't know
that's crazy live strong from before you
remember the yellow ones but then people
started having different colors and then
be like that's not the
strongest live live stream oh right yeah
yeah i don't know well speaking of like
money and all that stuff
um getting loans is pretty good
if you need to clear your debt and all
that because today's video is sponsored
by upstart payments
so if you're still needlessly throwing
away money every month at high
interest credit card debt it's time you
checked out upstart the revolutionary
online lending platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score
because we all know that sometimes you
try to get a loan or you try to get a
line of credit it's really difficult
because they have a very cookie-cutter
way of doing it
but unlike other lenders upstart can
reward you based on your education and
job history in the form of a smarter
rate you don't need a degree or diploma
to apply though
yeah so when i wish i had this during
college or right when i graduated
because i had
so much credit card debt and it was like
at
20 apr it was insane and
it just kept man i i was just paying off
the interest and i i couldn't pay off my
debt
and if it wasn't for um being accepted
to a zero percent credit card and i
i consolidated all my loans i think i'd
probably be still paying for that debt
right now
so this is pretty awesome yeah so so
basically what you guys want to do is
free yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt and get
back to using your money
your way with upstart okay so see why
upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
5 rating on trustpilot and hurry to
upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record nelson would you move to vegas
no why oh why because i like
the uh the not just economical
opportunities but i like the
i like the environment of california
right i can go to the beach i can go to
the mountains i can do everything within
like
just a few hours before lunch you know
yeah
i mean you can catch a flight that's
only 45 minutes and then go to the beach
and then come back here again they have
30 dollar flights
look at that yeah well that is cheaper
than you can't make it back before lunch
i could top you i could top you so in
vegas if you like snow snowboarding
there's uh mount charleston there is 30
minute drive
right if you like the beach there's the
mandalay bay
hello it's very similar there's a wave
pool
yup you don't get to have the nice tar
that washes up on the beach that you do
in l.a
true the beaches are way too nice in
vegas
they were making an artificial beach for
a while they just gave up on it really
yeah where it was i don't know in vegas
you know there's that las vegas lake
with all the chemicals and parasites too
you mean the pools and each there's like
a big
like man-made lake i think it's called
las vegas lake mead right
isn't there like tahoe around there too
no that's reno
right quite of a drive
yeah it's like a while it's like going
to san francisco or something all right
i take it back all right i [ __ ]
danced moving to vegas because you were
like i don't want to ruin vegas i love
vegas i love the magic of vegas yeah
i might move to nevada he likes money
too much
i'll see it depends it really really
depends because if i
really needed to because i'm not at a
point where i need to
do tech stuff and then get all
complicated with that stuff
uh but if i got to that point what i
would do
is i would definitely move there and i
would airbnb in california love it
why not or i get a van i live van life
oh
that's my crypto cash out plan yeah that
is so cool because i i'm never home
anyway
so like well i'm not i'm home now
because i have to be because of
quarantine right but
[ __ ] nice safe i know i thought i was
looking to i'm like well joe you should
be at home right now
oh well i'm doing social distancing
sports that's kind of the [ __ ] that i've
been doing whatever
i picked up uh surfing back up mountain
biking
paddle boarding i'm just chance of
getting wetsuits
i heard y'all gonna do bodyboarding yeah
hell yeah i already ordered
two boards which boards did you get i
don't know is that a body glove
boards i was just cause a moray body
board isn't like a boogie board is that
an old meal
a boogie board i was just telling casey
how excited i am for you guys to get
into this for five days and then give up
on it
so true yeah it's i think it's the
easiest
uh water sport to learn yeah i don't
know unless you nose dive and then you
flip and then you go oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
don't you just like dive into waves
basically well it's the easiest to get
started
but then to actually do it the right way
it's actually pretty hard right
to get in the barrel and then too crazy
yeah that's that's hard but the kind
where you're just like
yeah yeah that's the easiest but then to
actually do it against i feel
like to do the legit way you need like
fins and everything so oh really
you have to do like bodyboarding yes you
need to use fins because
like compared to a surfboard you're
floating on top so you can paddle a lot
easier
on a bodyboard half your body stuck in
the water so it's too much drag so if
you're trying to catch big waves you
can't do it but for me like this
like what bart did that's all
uh this way straight the real way is
going this way it's going
uh like perpendicular to the waves so
the waves are pushing into the sand that
way the railway
what's the thrill of it it's like a
sleeping slide okay well yeah
it's it's fun steve no no no no if
you're doing it professionally though i
might say what's what's better than the
one that i've done they do it
professionally which i'm not holding a
beer and i'm like [ __ ]
like actual competition just like
surfing it's just as big as surfing
yeah and they do flips and then they
freaking swirl and all this [ __ ]
the frisbee thing then there there
should be anything because i i got
really surprised that there's
professional frisbee thrower people
well it's not that i mean they're speed
walking so that's true
i try it so i'm actually really good at
walking fast and then i was like
i wonder if i could get a [ __ ]
olympic gold medal so i went on
uh just even just look at state records
i looked it up something i'm going to
complete this [ __ ] because i
walk really fast oh my god and then for
the guys that are speed walking
they could walk a mile in under five
minutes that's faster than a run
yeah i can't even run that fast i'm like
it's still not gonna get you on a
wheaties box though
they're gone i don't know but i'm like
there goes my friend imagine a post
they're like dude even
shoe companies don't sponsor them no you
could know how do they make a living
you know that you know what happens to
companies they cost you companies two
companies laugh at them and hang up the
phone i know right
they're like you yeah damn they must
have like the most
well-oiled hips ever like walk them all
in my shoes [ __ ] crazy my grandma
that's how she would work out she would
always dance but she would like
she would dance like that like heavily
like hips maybe she should have been
sponsored and she'd be like speed
walking around the neighborhood i'm like
what the [ __ ] have you guys ever seen
that olympic event it looks so
[ __ ] stupid it looks uh like
either running or speed walking but they
purposely
wet a part of the track right so they're
going this way
and then every every lap they have to
wet their shoes
like their ankles get submerged you
don't talk about this is the current
event
oh it sounds like you're making the show
oh i swear to god it's
it's like imagine running 20 laps and
every to every one
you have to submerge it up oh why
like weigh them down like an extra and
they come out of it with like
washing speed walking you said it's like
speed walking or running and then
there's
uh a wet porsche i don't know why
buffalo wild wings probably eating wings
and seeing it on tv or something did you
try to compete with dan
on speed walking who's dan what dad dan
our uh
our food group dan i think you did
i didn't smoked his ass he smoked really
yeah i think in japan we did it
he's speedwalks dan's always challenging
people to speed walking oh no
that's why i know i'm good like i smoke
the [ __ ] out of him
and then that's when i look on the
website and i'm like
i can't i'm not even like what is your
time what is your time then i never time
you should at least time yourself i've
timed him with my eyes and it looks
pretty bad
how do you even challenge somebody to
speed walking i know and how is somebody
so threatened that they're like
okay take your challenge
i got challenged t1 by dan yeah
we were at smorgasburg and i lost i bet
i could beat you over there without
running
no he was like yeah he's like do you
walk i don't know how he got into it i
don't even know how the challenge went
down
but i had to say yeah and then we went
for it
yeah no you didn't go for it because you
would be running if you went for it
you kind of you kind of like yeah you
kind of moved but i would say for speed
walking
they should make it like a leg length
limit not a weight limit
oh yeah because if you have longer legs
you have more of a
you know how like they have like in
boxing and all this they have different
weight classes oh yeah they should have
limb classes man because he's got longer
limbs so he has more reach
do they even have classes for like speed
yeah lengthy events like nah someone's
got to be running a scam out there right
oh yeah his little sports song is just
like like like for running and all that
[ __ ]
there's no classes right it's like you
could be however tall you want to be
yeah i know
i wonder what kind of injuries they get
knee ones
ankle ones i'm like is there like hip
splits watch they get broken arms like
that's the most common injury for
walking
maybe you're like pumping so hard my
shoulder
like dislocate your [ __ ] or is it like
if you if you get injured your doctor
laughs at you
that's pretty good injury from walking
you're a [ __ ] their number one
most uh dangerous one is is tripping and
falling
you're stubborn you're tough stubborn
you're don't tripping and falling
damn that's a lame ass entry to have
dude cause they have to lift their
feet really like just a little bit right
they don't go really high up
because you always have to have a foot
on the ground right that's what makes it
walking all right because running it can
come up right can we make a sports movie
about speed walking yeah can you imagine
the human being that dedicates their
life
to this sport it's pretty great i just
get the episode from malcolm in the
middle
you guys remember that no the dad was
like competing and speed walking
but then like he was competing against
his neighbor i think but the neighbor
was cheating because every other step he
took
he took a little skip oh my god
that was a great show cranston was great
you